We knew that if we were going to tell a story that was inspired by Colombia,...
...we wanted it to feel true.
We went and visited the Cocora Valley,...
...one of the most beautiful places I've ever been to.
We knew this is where the home of the Madrigals should be.
This movie, it's about family and your role within your family.
I hope that people go see it with their families.
I think people will see themselves in the different family members.
We have an amazing family.
It's just a joyous experience.
To me, it's really important to tell stories...
...where there's goodness and hope in the world.
Music can help tell stories in an animated realm.
In "Encanto," working on original songs with 12 original characters,...
...it's really, really exciting.
There's this family, the Madrigal family,...
...and they've been blessed with these magical gifts.
These characters are having emotional breakthroughs and reunions all in song.
The filmmakers put a great amount of faith in me to be able to musicalize this.
Colombia has a lot of rich musical traditions within itself...
...that are unique to Colombia, but also there's an incredible amount of variety.
Colombian music is special because we do it with our heart,...
...you know, we do it with love.
There's a beautiful story in every song.
"Colombia, Mi Encanto," I wanted to just write the most joyous song possible,...
...a love letter to Colombia itself.
Obviously, Carlos Vives is a worldwide music figure.
I was in love with his music already.
That song is so inspired by his writings,...
...and so to have him sing on that is like a dream.